en 2017
vous avez filmé une campagne aussi où
vous êtes vous êtes beaucoup déplacé et
on vous a senti à la fin de la campagne
fatigué c'est pour cette campagne là je
sens beaucoup plus en forme je sens
contraire qu'on avait l'impression que
vous avez démarré comme un diesel et
puis là ça va beaucoup mieux tiré on le
dit on va on va sans parler ce soir lors
du débat entre les deux tours je vous ai
senti fatigué je sentis éreinté par
toute la campagne là on vous sent plus
en forme même physiquement voilà vous
avez l'air à et on apprend aussi un
c'est l'expérience est là on sait qu'il
faut s'économiser la dernière fois c'est
vrai que objectivement je ne mettais pas
économisé donc je suis arrivé au second
tour dans un état de fatigue
certains ça a joué sur joue ça oui bien
sûr que ça joue bien sûr c'est
évidemment quand on est en forme
physiquement ça se ressent dans les
interventions que vous faites dans les
meetings que vous faites dans les
émissions que vous faites c'est pour ça
que là vous ai dit je referai pas pareil
si vous êtes au deuxième tour le second
sondage sur l'essentiel est de mettre un
tout petit peu de côté parfois
d'accessoires ça si si vous revenez si
on regarde les sondages vous êtes
actuellement au deuxième tour face à
emmanuel macron donc ce serait le match
retour 1 vous feriez pas du tout pareil
que que ce que vous avez fait lors du
débat n'empêche que vous changeriez
changerait tout d'abord parce qu'on
n'est pas du tout dans la news est de
trouver comment on n'est pas le dire ou
non plus dans la même situation oui je
veux dire emmanuel macron vient d'être
président pendant cinq ans il a un bilan
il va falloir qu'il en rende compte même
si pour l'instant et il n'a
manifestement pas envie de faire je
dirais qu'il faut un moment qui se
confronte à ses adversaires marine le
pen entre nous avant de parler de ce
débat du second tour si vous aviez
thiais si vous aviez été à la place
d'emmanuel matin il est président
sortant il ya 30% d'intentions de vote
au premier tour ils cessent de monter
dans les sondages de semaine en semaine
est ce que vous auriez pris le risque
d'aller débattre d'aller aujourd'hui si
j'ai franchement si j'étais à sa place
je ferais le minimum et on peut le
comprendre ce que vous auriez pas fait
comme lui non je crois pas que j'aurais
fait comme lui parce que moi je crois
qu'il faut qu'il y ait un moment donné
une confrontation entre le président
sortant et des adversaires politiques
particulièrement peut-être pour le
président sortant justement parce
qu'elle est sortant parce que sinon
encore une fois on arrive au second tour
sans qu'il ait jamais été confronté
véritablement à une adversité à un débat
politique et ça je pense que ça pose un
problème alors il l'avait fait en 2007
il n'était pas président il aucun
président de la feh lui se dit moi je
suis et je vais me dit dans les sondages
s'est déjà entretenu ensuite eu déjà
donné finalistes je vais attendre
l'homme est d'accord mais ils avaient
dit qu'ils étaient différents des autres
donc faut savoir si les pics les rangs
des autres il fait pas comme les
instruments et différenciant et on a
bien fait et que en réalité il est en
train d'essayer de préserver une forme
de capital et qu'il aimerait bien même
tenté de laisser penser que cette
élection ne serait pas une et qu'il
s'agirait là en fait d'un pur acte
administratif
d'ailleurs il annonce d'ores et déjà que
il
procédera à la dissolution de
l'assemblée pour qu'elle ait lieu plus
tôt comme s'il était déjà élu alors moi
je viens juste vous dire que il n'est
pas élu vous y croyez oui bien sûr j'y
crois j'y crois j'y crois beaucoup
d'abord parce que je pense que le second
tour est une nouvelle élection que des
mecs compteurs à zéro après le oui c'est
ça les créateurs sont allés euros
vraiment on repart à zéro et on repart à
zéro et par conséquent la question se
posera savez on dit au premier tour on
choisit au second tour on écarte bien je
crois qu'il y a des dizaines de millions
de français qui veulent écarter emmanuel
macron parce qu'ils sont profondément en
désaccord avec la politique qui a été
menée